here's something really weird from a
Donald Trump rally that I want to tell
you about Donald Trump identified a
black man at a rally in Kinston North
Carolina as a protester and referred to
him as a thug and asked him actually
whether he was paid $1500 to be a thug
Trump had this guy removed from his
event it turns out that in spite of
being black
this was the rarely spotted black Trump
supporter and I know that mathematically
there aren't very many black Trump
supporters at one point Donald Trump was
polling I believe it was in Ohio yeah
in Ohio Trump was polling 0% with
african-americans but at least pretend
like there's a black guy there who might
support you if you're Trump I'm talking
about CJ Kerry who is black he told the
local paper there in North Carolina that
he supports Trump and wants to encourage
him to be more inclusive of black people
and women and people with disabilities
and college students he's on record as
supporting Trump because he is quote
honest according to the 62 year old
Trump supporter he had a note that he
brought about his ideas for the campaign
and he was about 20 or 30 feet from the
stage waving it and Trump began slamming
him referring to him as a thug and
having the guy kicked out this is a
trump supporter mind you they'll take a
look at the video we have a protester by
the way will you paid $1,500 to be a
thug where's the broadcast
was he paid all right you can get him
out get him out
out
yeah recent polling puts Donald Trump's
african-american support at 5.6 percent
in the United States Hillary Clinton at
84% according to CNBC this is just so
funny in so many ways on the one hand
Pat mathematically it is true that it's
not very likely that black people in the
crowd are supporting Trump although it
is a self-selected group so you might
say well even if only five six five
point six percent nationally of black
people support Trump if they go to a
Trump event you might say well it's more
likely than than one in 20 but at the
same time the writing off of this guy as
obviously a protesting thug it's if
you're trying to appeal to the black
vote this is not the way to do it no
it's not gonna court black supporters
whatsoever and it's just crazy to see
the mob mentality take over at these
Trump rallies and they're just gonna
follow whatever their leader says to do
kick him out
will pay for his legal fees whatever it
is and every single time I see a
headline about what Trump did or said
this time Trump calls a black supporter
a thug and kicks him out I always think
I'm sure the headline is
sensationalizing and if I actually read
the article or watch the video it's not
as described it can't possibly be that
bad they must be exaggerating and then I
read the article or I watch the video
and it's usually as bad or worse than
the headline actually suggests and this
yet another example of that send me your
thoughts about any of these stories I'm
on twitter at D Pakman and I will remind
you the 2017 David Pakman show calendar
is now available it is available at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 you
can even get it for free with a yearly
membership at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17